WITH A JAMPACKED INGRAHAM ANGLE
TONIGHT FROM WASHINGTON.
LET'S DIVE RIGHT IN.
THE ESCALATION CAUCUS, THAT IS
THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT ANGLE.
I WANT TO CLUE YOU IN ON
SOMETHING.
EARLIER TODAY "THE INGRAHAM
ANGLE" YIELDED INQUIRY BOTH
PERPLEXING AND REVEALING FROM
OUR DEAR FRIENDS AT NEWSWEEK.
APPARENTLY AS INTREPID REPORTER
SOME FELLOW NAMED GERARD BASED
IN THE UK WAS STUNNED THAT THE
ANGLE HAD THE NERVE TO RAISE
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE WISDOM OF
SENDING THE SOVIET ERA MIGS FRO
POLAND TO UKRAINE.
WHAT DID SHE MEAN BY THIS?
WHAT PART OF THIS IS CONFUSING.
ESCALATING THE CONFLICT DOESN'T
JUST MEAN MORE RUSSIAN TROOPS
WOULD DIE, IT MEANS MORE
UKRAINIAN CIVILIANS COULD DIE A
WELL.
NOW, IF PUTIN IS CLEARLY THE
MEGALOMANIAC THAT MANY OF MEET
HIM OUT TO BE COMMIT THAN HE
KNOWS HOW HE WOULD RESPOND TO
AMERICA ENGINEERING THAT MADE
TRANSFER, BUT THE UNKNOWNS ARE
PART OF EVERY WORK ABOUT WHICH
IS WHY EVERY STEP MUST BE
CAREFULLY GAMED OUT THE
QUESTIONS DIDN'T STOP THERE.
LAURA ALSO OPPOSED THE CLAIMS
MADE BY TOM COTTON AND MITT
ROMNEY ON THE IMPORTANCE OF
DOING THIS.
WHAT DID SHE BELIEVE COULD
HAPPEN AND HOW COULD THINGS
ESCALATE?
AS FAR AS OPPOSING THOSE TWO,
BIG DEAL, WE LOVE TOM COTTON,
BUT DOES NEWSWEEK ONLY APPROVE
OF CERTAIN REPUBLICANS OPPOSING
OTHER REPUBLICANS?
AFTER ALL, THE PRESS CORPS HAS
HOT AFFAIR GOING
ON WITH LISA CHENEY AND ADAM CA
FIGURE.
OUR SO-CALLED REPORTERS REALLY
THIS LOST?
HOOTON'S ENTIRE JUSTIFICATION
HAS BEEN CONCERN ABOUT NATO
ENCROACHMENT TOWARD RACHA.
IT WOULD SEEM LOGICAL TO SEND
MIGS INTO THE UKRAINE COULD GIV
HIM SEE I TOLD YOU SO MOMENT.
SO WHY IS IT UNREASONABLE TO
POSIT AT THIS REAL POSSIBILITY?
ANSWER, IT'S NOT VERY IN FACT,
IT'S THE RESPONSIBLE THING TO DO
.
THE QUESTION WE SHOOT RIGHT BAC
TO NEWSWEEK IS A SIMPLE ONE, WH
AREN'T PEOPLE WHO CALL
THEMSELVES REAL REPORTERS ASKIN
THE UNCOMFORTABLE QUESTIONS?
DIDN'T THEY LEARN ANYTHING FROM
THE LAST TIME THEY THREW IN WIT
THE WARHOL CONSENSUS?
I SHOULD KNOW, I WAS ONE OF
THOSE PEOPLE WHO REFLEXIVELY
JOINED THE WAGE WAR AT ANY COST
BANDWAGON AFTER 9/11.
ANYONE ELSE FEEL LIKE THIS IS
KIND OF A BACK TO THE FUTURE
MOMENT AT THIS POINT?
>> WHY DO YOU FEEL LIKE THE WES
IS NOT COMPLETELY EMBRACING THA
IN SAYING THIS IS THE WAR AND W
NEED TO GET INTO A.
>> THEY'RE ARE STILL OTHER
OPTIONS ON THE TABLE.
WHY GO BACK?
>> Laura: THE DEPARTMENT OF
WAR IT NBC-TV IMPRESSED JEN
PSAKI YESTERDAY.
>> THERE IS A GROWING COURSE
THAT I SAY NOW IS THE TIME.
HAS THE PRESIDENT REALLY
RECONSIDERED HIS STANCE AT ALL?
>> THEY HAVE SEVERAL SQUADRON O
VISION CAPABLE AIRCRAFT.
THAT ARE NOT BEING UTILIZED FOR
THIS IS THE ASSESSMENT BY OUR
DEFENSE DEPARTMENT.
>> IF I WERE I WOULD APPEAL TO
AMERICANS, ANYTHING TO GET MORE
WEAPONS AND BUY MORE TIME.
I GET IT.
HIS ASSAULT ON CIVILIANS IS PUR
EVIL, WE ALL SEE A.
SO THE ZELENSKYY CALL FOR
ANNUITIZE FLY ZONE IS
UNDERSTANDABLE, BUT WHEN
AMERICAN POLITICIANS TRY TO USE
THIS SENDING MAKES TO UKRAINE A
SOME KIND OF WITNESS TEST FOR
PATRIOTISM, WE FIND IT REPUGNANT
, AS IF ANYONE TRYING
TO PRETEND THAT NONE OF THIS
POSES A MASSIVE AND POTENTIAL
RISK TO AMERICA.
TO GET YOUR TELLING ME
LOGISTICALLY, THAT'S WHAT
STANDING BETWEEN INNOCENT BABIE
AND MOTHERS AND UKRAINE?
WE CAN'T GET DEBTS TO PILOTS WH
ARE ABLE TO FLY THEM.
>> I FEEL FULLY COMMITTED DOING
EVERYTHING IN OUR POWER TO HELP
THE PEOPLE OF UKRAINE AGAINST
THE MONSTROUS ACTIONS OF
VLADIMIR PUTIN.
THAT MEANS GETTING THE PEOPLE O
UKRAINE MIGS THEY WOULD NEED TO
FIGHT AND SHOOT DOWN SOME OF
THEIR RUSSIAN AIRCRAFT RAFIKI
HISTORY WARNS US IF WE DON'T AC
NOW AND IF WE DON'T ACT STRONGLY
, HE KEEP MILITARY
STRATEGIST WHO SPECIALIZE IN
BATTLEFIELD TACTICS AND GAME OU
EVERY MOVE AND EVERY STEP OF TH
WAY THEY ASKED SERIOUS QUESTION
LIKE WILL MIGS ACTUALLY HELPED
TURN THE TIDE IN UKRAINE AND CA
UKRAINE EVEN MAINTAIN THESE
OLDER FIGHTER PLANES, OR IS THE
MEDIA'S POSITION THAT IT'S
BETTER TO CONSIDER THESE ISSUES
AFTER WE HAVE SPENT BILLIONS
REPLACING THE POLAND MIGS.
NOW, THIS BEEN THIS LATER
APPROACH IS HOW THE U.S. ENDED
UP WITHOUT A VICTORY IN IRAQ AN
IN AN EMBARRASSING DEFEAT IN
AFGHANISTAN.
WE SPENT TRILLIONS, WE LOST
THOUSANDS OF OUR BRAVE TROOPS,
WE WILL ASK CONTRACTORS AND
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF IRAQI
CIVILIANS TO FIGHT A WAR THAT
CREATED AN EXODUS OF IRAQI
CHRISTIANS IN ALSO THE RISE OF
ISIS.
SADDAM WAS GONE, A GREAT THING,
BUT MUCH OF IRAQ WAS AS WELL.
A TOTAL NIGHTMARE.
THIS IS PRECISELY THE TIME, NOW
IS THE TIME FOR VIGOROUS AND
OPEN DEBATE.
ONE VOICE THAT SHOULD BE HEARD
IS THAT OF U.S. NAVY RESERVE
OFFICER WHO WRITES IN FOREIGN
POLICY THAT MOST OF UKRAINE'S
FIGHTER AIRCRAFT ARE STILL IN
THE FIGHT, FLYING APPROXIMATELY
5-10 MISSIONS PER DAY USING A
POOL OF ABOUT 50 JETS.
RUSSIAN AIRCRAFT ARE FLYING
NEARLY TO HUNDRED MISSIONS PER
DAY, BUT KEEPING THEIR PLANES
PRIMARILY WITHIN RUSSIAN
AIRSPACE.
BOTH SIDES ARE LIKELY EXERCISIN
EXTREME CAUTION TO AVOID GROUND
BASED AIR DEFENSE SYSTEM.
GIVING THIS KNOWLEDGE, AIR
SUPERIORITY ASSETS WOULD NOT
IMMEDIATELY IMPROVE THE UKRAINE
MILITARY SITUATION.
THERE'S MORE, THE POLAND MIGS
ARE DECADES OLD AND MANY WE'RE
HAND-ME-DOWNS WHEN THEY RECEIVE
THEIR PEER DIVIDERS, ESPECIALLY
OLDER ONES REQUIRE CONSIDERABLE
MAINTENANCE AS WELL AS AN
INSURED PIPELINE OF SPARE PARTS
AMMUNITION.
THE CAPABILITY TO DISDAIN THOSE
EXTRA AIRCRAFT IN THE UKRAINE I
UNCLEAR.
SO ASKING HOW SOVIET ERA MIGS
WILL HOLD UP AGAINST YOUR RUSSI
DEBTS WITH ADVANCED CAPABILITIE
AS AN ENTIRE NUTLEY RATIONAL
QUESTION.
SO WHY IS THE ESTABLISHMENT SO
AFRAID TO ANSWER IT?
WHY ARE THEY AFRAID TO EVEN
ALLOW THE QUESTION TO BE ASKED
AT ALL?
BUT, THERE IS AT LEAST ONE
DEMOCRAT WHO DARED TO RAISE A
LEGITIMATE POINT.
WASHINGTON CONGRESSMAN AND CHAI
OF THE HOUSE ARMS COMMITTEE SAI
THE MIG WOULDN'T LAST A SECOND
IN UKRAINIAN AIRSPACE RIGHT NOW.
MAYBE HE'S RIGHT, MAYBE HE'S NOT
, BUT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
MUST BE TOLD THAT THE RISKS OF
ESCALATING THINGS WITH RUSSIA
ARE NOT NEGLIGIBLE.
IT MAY IN FACT DRAW US EVEN
CLOSER TO A DIRECT CONFRONTATIO
WITH RUSSIA, WHICH AS WE ALL
KNOW IS A NUCLEAR POWER.
IS THIS WHAT AMERICANS REALLY
WANT?
IF NOT, ISN'T IT INCUMBENT UPON
THE ELECTIVE REPRESENTATIVES TO
STOP AND DO A MEANINGFUL
RISK-BENEFIT ANALYSIS?
AS FOR THE LAPTOP WORRIERS AT
NEWSWEEK, PERHAPS THEY WOULDN'T
BE WRITING FOR A DIGITAL ONLY
PUBLICATION IF THE WRITERS HAD
THE ABILITY OR THE DESIRE TO
STEP BACK FROM THE UNFOLDING
TRAGEDY, AS HORRIFIC AS IT IS,
AND IDENTIFY ALL THE PARTIES WH
ARE PROLONGING A WAR WHERE THER
ARE NO WINNERS.
OH, AND WAS FORGOT, HE ONLY
REACHED OUT TO US FOR COMMENT
LESS THAN 20 MINUTES BEFORE HE
PUBLISHED HIS SILLY LITTLE PIEC
ABOUT US.
AT 7:00 A.M.
SUCH AS JOURNALISM IN 2022.
FIFTH-GRADE ANTI